and yet another indicator that the
mainstream media is rife with corruption
and conflicts of interest CNN has now
hired Laura Jarrett
daughter of Valerie Jarrett to cover
president Trump's department of justice
as the blaze reports CNN's how -
Jarrett's background defending companies
and individuals in government
investigations brought by the Justice
Department Valerie Jarrett wasn't just
President Obama's top advisor
she's also personally close to the
Obamas it's the extent that she's
reportedly moving in with them in their
new Washington DC digs Jarrett called
Trump's election a punch in the stomach
soul-crushing according to Vanity Fair
Laura Jarrett is dedicated to quote
promoting civil rights and social
equality for women and minorities so
she's probably going to be completely
objective about the Trump administration
you'd think right look this is nothing
new from the mainstream media democratic
party complex Ben Rhodes the national
security adviser to President Obama who
actively lied to the entire media about
the Iran deal his brother - David Rhodes
president of CBS ABC News correspondent
claire shipman she's the wife of jay
carney former obama press secretary
George Stephanopoulos ABC News's leading
anchor he's a former Clinton staffer Ben
Sherwood president of Disney ABC
Television Group his brother - former
Obama special assistant Elizabeth
sherwood-randall the media claimed that
such relationships have no bearing on
coverage maybe or maybe people with
close relationships to those in power
tend to favor those people in their
coverage after all that's the entire
basis of the rumors about presidents
Trump's conflicts of interest with
regard to his businesses which are now
supposedly run by his kids their
relationship makes him more likely to
acting corrupt fashion to benefit those
businesses why wouldn't that same logic
apply to the media there's nothing wrong
with assigning Valerie Jarrett's kid to
cover the DOJ but there is something
wrong with pretending objectivity when
it is clearer every single day that such
objectivity is a figment of the media's
imagination I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
okay lots to talk about today we'll
start with everything going on with Jeff
sessions in just a moment but before we
do that we have to say thank you to our
advertisers over at wink so if you are
somebody who doesn't know how does what
a sommelier is doesn't know what a good
wine is doesn't know what wine goes with
what food you need to go over to my
friends at wink con this is formerly
Club W it's winc WI and c.com and what
they do is you go there and they give
you the survey and they ask you what
kind of foods you like what kind of
tastes you like and then they recommend
a wine that is specifically for you a
wine that is personalized to your taste
buds and it's great if you know what
your friends like and you know what
they're having for dinner and you want
to bring over a bottle of wine that
matches what they're having and want to
look like you're not an ignoramus about
wine which I am the wine is apparently
fantastic people around the office have
been drunk for months off of link calm
wine which is why the quality of the
podcast has been so poor lately but wink
calm is the place that you can go for
that kind of great wine wink is offering
my listeners $20 off right now when you
go to try wink calm slash pen try wink
calm slash man winc calm slash Ben and
they cover the shipping so you get that
fine wine personalized to your palate
delivered right to your door and it's
really cheap I mean a lot of these
bottles mine are like 10 bucks apiece
you can get a couple of bottles of wine
20 bucks off when you go to try wink
calm
slash Ben you get complimentary shipping
right now try wingtok on slash Ben make
sure that you use the slash Ben so you
get that $20 discount and also so that
they know that we sent you okay so we
begin the day with the story of the day
and the story of the day is supposedly
supposedly that Jeff Sessions is the
most nefarious character that ever was
so the Attorney General for the Trump
administration is supposedly this this
guy who is just awful awful awful why is
he so awful because he met with the
Russkies he met with the Rooskies just
like everybody else in the Trump
administration apparently he met with
the evil evil evil Rooskies and that
means that he has to be he has to be
stopped right I mean the fact is that
the the Rooskies have been have been
trying to get the Trump administration
in their pocket and now here comes Jeff
Sessions trying to explain you know
trying to work the back room basically
here is the problem with with all of
that okay so there
problems with this particular set of
nonsense some of the I'll go through the
entire story from the beginning because
a little bit confusing so here it is
he's the latest figure to come under
heavy fire here's what you need to know
he testified back in January I guess
that he hadn't met with the Russians
when he was just a senator he was not
yet AG and it was unclear whether he
testified he hadn't met the Russians in
his capacity as somebody on the Trump
campaign or whether he hadn't met the
Russians in his capacity at all what he
said al franken asked sessions what he
would do if he learned of communications
with the Russians from the Trump
campaign and sessions said I've been
called the surrogate a time or two in
that campaign I did not have
communications with the Russians so is
that a denial of any contact or is a
denial of contact as a surrogate not
really clear because he could say look
as a senator he I met with the Russian
ambassador but we didn't discuss the
campaign so it didn't have anything to
do with Trump Senator Pat Leahy asked
sessions in writing quote have you been
in contact with anyone connected to any
part of the Russian government about the
2016 election either before or after
Election Day and sessions said no and
sessions issued a statement saying he
did not meet with any Russian officials
now to discuss issues of the campaign so
now he's changing his story a little bit
so the sort of back and forth has really
hurt sessions because it now turns out
that sessions met twice that sessions
met with the the Russians two times so
what does that mean
did anything nefarious happen no
evidence that anything nefarious
happened he could have met with them to
tell you son the Armed Services
Committee he could have met with them to
talk about that sort of stuff is it
possible he talked with them about the
campaign sure but the problem is that
now that he testified in front of
Congress that he didn't or at least he
didn't in a certain capacity in the
language is a little bit vague that a
lot of people calling for his recusal
there are a bunch of people in the
Senate who have said that they don't
routinely meet with the Russians 20
lawmakers from the Armed Services
Committee told the Washington Post they
didn't meet with the Russian ambassador
last year but a bunch of Senators have
also said it's not out of the realm of
possibility or out of the realm of
normalcy for Senators to meet with the
Russian ambassador you know Claire
McCaskill who has said that sessions
should resign for perjury she said she's
never met with the Russian ambassador
and then she turns out she met with him
in 2013 so a lot of these senators have
met with the Russian ambassador this
looks like a lot of smoke and no fire it
doesn't even look like real smoke just
like a bunch of crap honestly it looks
like a smear job out to get sessions the
day after Donald Trump goes on his
triumphant tour because he gave a good
speech to the joint session of Congress
so all the Democrats are universally
calling for
his resignation and this is where the
Democrats are really really stupid so
they don't have the capacity to just in
moderate fashion say something obvious
like maybe he should recuse himself and
that'd be one thing you could say okay
look whether he did something good or
bad or not it doesn't really matter now
people are gonna think no matter what he
does it's corrupt so he should recuse
himself that's a fair argument it's a
fair argument I think it's a great
argument but it's a fair argument but
instead they're saying he should resign
so you have people like Nancy Pelosi
saying after lying under oath to
Congress about his communications with
the Russians the Attorney General must
resign and then she was joined in that
call by Elizabeth Warren among others
listen Eric Holder the Obama Attorney
General he didn't resign despite a
scandal plagued career ranging from fast
and furious to overseeing journalists in
attempting to prosecute journalists he
was actually held in contempt of
Congress and he didn't resign Loretta
Lynch as you recall the Attorney General
under under President Obama after Holder
she refused to recuse herself from the
investigation of Hillary Clinton she
said she wasn't going to interfere
unless it went the way she didn't want
in which case you would interfere so for
Democrats to suddenly say that sessions
has to recuse himself based on he once
met with the Russian ambassador is
really over the topic but saying they
should resign is super-duper-duper over
the top Trump says it's a partisan hit
job and he's basically right the White
House deputy press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders she says this is
the latest attack against the Trump
administration by partisan Democrats
attorney General Sessions met with the
Ambassador in an official capacity as a
member of the Senate Armed Services
Committee which is entirely consistent
with his testimony it's no surprise
senator Al Franken is pushing this story
immediately following president Trump
successful address to the nation here's
my deal okay folks here's my deal I am
always going to call balls and strikes
I'm always going to call balls and
strikes no matter who's at bat because
that's all that matters is the balls and
the strikes what is right and what is
wrong not the person at bat
if Trump's a bat I'm gonna call balls
and strikes if the Democrats are a bet
I'm gonna call balls and strikes okay so
this one is a ball I'm sorry this is not
a major story there's no evidence that
that sessions is deliberately lying
about meeting with the Russian
ambassador for some nefarious reason
should he recuse himself as a second
question and that second question is
basically is he so compromised at this
point that any investigation he does
will be compromised that's possible that
is possible and there are good arguments
both ways on the one hand there's that
argument on the other hand there's the
argument that if anybody can basically
be prevented from doing their job by a
media and a democratic party that
insists that every minor problem is a
major problem then nothing's ever gonna
get done if you're accusing yourself
over I once met the Russian ambassador
at my office then what won't you recuse
yourself over what what can you actually
do that's a serious problem for the
Trump administration it looks in all
likelihood like sessions will just
recuse himself on this thing that
doesn't mean there will be a special
prosecutor by the way it just means that
his deputy will end up prosecuting this
thing and his deputy presumably would
probably act the same way that he would
because his deputy will be appointed in
coordination with President Trump by him
so you know the idea that he is going to
to somehow not be able to have control
over the investigation is just not true
as an example the Deputy Attorney
General for Loretta Lynch was that lady
who refused to prosecute Donald Trump's
executive order and ended up being fired
so the Deputy Attorney General ends up
looking a lot like the Attorney General
under whom they serve but here's my
bottom line this thing looks way
overblown even for people like me who
are suspicious of Donald Trump's
relations with the Russians because
there's a lot of smoke a lot of smoke
but we haven't seen on your real fire
yet even for somebody like me who looks
at Paul Manafort and says that's kind of
weird and looks at Donald Trump
constantly praising Putin this is well
that's kind of weird and looks at the
fact that that Michael Flynn was so warm
with Vladimir Putin and so that's kind
of weird even for me this is a nothing
burger of a story and again Paul's and
strikes are all the matters I'm not
gonna rip Trump for doing something I
don't think is particularly wrong that
said it's pretty clear that the
Democrats are losing their minds and
they're particularly losing their minds
over this this moment with Karen Owens
and I want to talk about this briefly
because we ran a story a couple of days
ago in which we talked about the
Democrats not standing up for for Karen
Owens and people took that to mean that
we were saying that they had never stood
up for Karen Owens we never claimed that
they never stood up for Karen Owens what
we said as I said on the podcast
yesterday was that the Democrats stood
at the beginning and then they sat down
and then they sat down and when people
say well they sat down it's not a big
deal then why is it that in all the
pictures you can see that half the room
is sitting and half the room is standing
if it wasn't coordinated if it wasn't a
matter of partisanship then why is it
that half the room is Stanny and half
from a sitting why wouldn't just be a
bunch of randos who are kind of standing
and sitting together why wouldn't some
Republicans have sit and some Democrats
said everybody just got tired and bored
and so they sat down but that's not what
it looks like you can
the pictures half the room is sitting
half the room is standing during the
second ovation not the initial ovation
everybody stands for the initial evasion
here's what I actually wrote okay
Democrats initially stood for the widow
but then they sat Trump didn't okay so I
was very clear about this nonetheless
Snopes in politifact instead of ranking
as half true or totally true the claim
that Democrats sat down for the video
they said that it was completely false
which I have pictures and so does Benny
Johnson Benny Johnson's the guy who
initially reported this from ia review
and he tweeted out pictures of keith
Ellison and and Debbie wasserman-schultz
sitting down in the middle of the second
ovation and you can see it in his
picture I'm looking at the picture right
now right before me and he's not the
only one I mean they're sitting down an
entire body of the Democratic Party is
sitting down Bernie Sanders and Nancy
Pelosi by the end are sitting down which
is exactly what we wrote in the piece
but again PolitiFact and Snopes and the
rest of these fact checkers our lefties
and so they feel the need to overreach
because they're desperate to disprove
the idea that democrats made a boo-boo
by not standing up the whole time which
they obviously should have okay that's
just one indicator of how the Democrats
are over playing their hand but they're
they're losing their minds in general
because anything anytime Trump does
something good and isn't a universal
crap show they begin to go crazy
so Michael Moore you know again going
off on this whole Karen Owens thing he's
suggesting that Donald Trump used the
seal widow so here's what he had to say
of course and that's why she's there as
a sort of fu to the nice people who are
criticizing him for this and this poor
woman this Widow who has lost her
husband she is in desperate grief right
now is in love with her husband's - and
in love with her husband what did you
think an and to use that has just put
another notch on his belt and what's he
thinking about my ratings okay and so
more is very upset okay as I said
yesterday two things can be true at once
one can be the Trump wanted to honor her
the second can be the Donald Trump was
using her as a political prop okay I'm
just gonna be perfectly frank about this
politicians use people as political
props all the time Barack Obama and
Hillary Clinton stood in front of the
flag-draped coffins from Benghazi and
lied to the families of Benghazi for
political gain
Barack Obama in 2014 invited a wounded
warrior to the State of the Union did he
do so because he was so respectful of
the troops or did he do so as a
political prop and the answer is maybe
both right it can be both
Barack Obama he did the same me he's
done the same routine multiple times
Hillary Clinton trotted out Kaiser Khan
right gold star family and this became a
major issue in the campaign
she tried out Kaiser Kahn to rip into
Donald Trump over a Kaiser Kunz son
being killed in Iraq right and and
hazard kind rips into Trump was that
Hillary Clinton using them as a prop
it's really funny every time somebody on
the right brings out a family member of
somebody who's been slain in the line of
duty then their political prop according
to the Democrats so when when
Republicans talked about Pat Smith who's
the mother of Shawn Smith who was killed
in Benghazi then she was just a
political prop but every time the
Democrats tried out a Cindy Sheehan or
every time they tried out the Jersey
girls you know from from 9/11 these are
heroes who cannot be questioned under
any circumstances here is the reality
politicians will always use people who
are suffering who oh they'll always use
victims as a little bit of political
theater they'll always do that that
doesn't change that doesn't change the
fact that these this woman wanted to be
there and I thought Mary Katharine ham
of CNN had the exact right take on this
which was you know the Ryan Owens Widow
Karen Owens she has every right to be
there she has every right to to feel the
applause of the entire nation shower
down upon her in thanks and one day
she'll be able to show her kids the tape
of when their father was cheered by the
entire nation at a State of the Union
address so you know the Democrats are
losing their minds over this Jake Tapper
at CNN who's reporting I generally like
he also went after Trump because Trump
at one point apparently had said about
the Yemen raid they lost Ryan and and
meaning the military meaning the
generals and Jake Tapper objected to
this meaning you authorized the raid why
don't you say we lost Ryan why do you
make it about they it's nitpicky they
lost right quote they lost Brian but
they didn't lose him we did we all did
as a nation and one might think that the
commander-in-chief who signed off on
that raid would also think in terms of
we lost Ryan accountability and
responsibility these are important
principles okay so you know this is a
little bit of an over state you let's
see what comes out about this Yemen raid
whether there was actual intelligence
gathered there's a lot of controversy
over that but you know trying to say
that the Trump is somehow disrespect
the memory of this guy I think that's an
overstatement Mike Pence I think hits
this right on the head he says all of
this is a great disservice to the family
that make you angry miss you seem like a
calm guy exactly that made me angry and
then make you angry it does a great
disservice to a great American family
and I think that that's totally fair I
mean ripping her and there are people
who ripped her saying that she was used
and she she allowed herself to be used
again it's her choice to be there if
you're gonna rip Trump for using her
then you have to show that he used her
and didn't honor her and I'm not sure
that that happened I think that's again
a wild overstatement by desperate
Democrats how desperate are the
Democrats at this point they're so
desperate that they're thinking toward
2020 and they're looking at their field
and they're realizing that there's their
field is barren there is nothing there
right there their field is just totally
empty so the question becomes okay well
if their field is totally empty who will
they go for they have an idea mm-hmm
their idea Oprah Winfrey oh yes here she
goes have you ever thought that given
the popularity you have we haven't
broken the glass ceiling yet for women
that you could actually run for
president and actually be elected
[Applause]
I I actually never thought that that was
I never considered the question even a
possibility
I just thought oh oh all right because
it's clear that you don't need
government experience to be like the
present state right I thought oh gee I
don't have the experience I don't know
enough I don't know
now I'm thinking oh okay so now they're
talking about Oprah is gonna will run
from and you knew that this is the
lesson the Democrats we're gonna take
away they're not gonna take away the
lesson that they have failed to appeal
to blue-collar people they're not gonna
take away the lesson that they had the
world's crappiest candidate in hillary
clinton cuz here's the reality if Joe
Biden runs in that election cycle very
high probability that Joe Biden is
President of the United States right now
they're not going to take away the right
lessons from this instead they're gonna
take away Donald Trump as a celebrity
and now we need our own celebrity
because this is how political parties
think because political parties our
parties of groupthink and stupidity so
it'll be Tom Hanks or Oprah Winfrey and
the Democrats are over the moon about
this and we'll get to Chris Matthews you
say well hey stay by Oprah I'll get to
that in a second but for that you have
to go over to Daley wire.com and become
a subscriber if you want to watch it
live you can be part of the mailbag
today we're gonna do a lot of live
questions from the mailbag so finally
your opportunity to sound off at daily
wire.com eight bucks a month gets you
access to daily wire.com you can watch
this show live you can also watch Clavin
show live well you're going to have we
right now we're giving away free copies
of the DVD of the arroyo which is the
fictional film set on the southern
border about the the drug cartels taking
over the southern border and using it
for illegal immigration and such it's a
very good film and you can check it out
over at our Facebook page as well but if
you want a copy of it I'm getting for
free by being an annual subscriber to
daily wire.com or if you want to listen
to the show later go over to SoundCloud
or iTunes and if you listen over at
iTunes then make sure that you leave a
review we are the top conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]